merci gignac a cessé d'être en direct
avec nous ce matin alors boris johnson
est le premier chef d'état d'un
américain contacté par joe biden
qu'est-ce que cela dit sur le futur des
relations entre les deux pays
à vrai dire c'est un peu surprenant
on pensait plutôt que l'aube hayden
allait téléphoner à angela merkel ou
d'aller téléphoner macron et le fait
d'avoir choisi qui fêtera le bretagne et
johnson c'est ainsi qu'il n'est pas
particulièrement encourageant pour
l'union européenne
alors est ce qu'il a voulu faire preuve
de tradition sachant évidemment la
grande bretagne et les etats unis ont
toujours relations publiques chez qui
parlent la même langue
est ce qu'il a voulu aussi sondé le
terrain par rapport à la grande-bretagne
qui vient de sortir de l'espace
communautaire
c'est possible mais cela nous fait lever
ainsi quelques dents dans d'autres
capitales européennes j'en suis persuadé
alors des deux côtés les déclarations
sont un petit peu flou c'est à downing
street on évoque ouvertement un
partenariat commercial du côté de la
maison blanche on reste beaucoup plus
réservé pourquoi cette position des
états unis
alors ceci est moins surprenant c'est à
dire que la de l'administration
britannique mark ronson doit maintenant
après avoir quitté l'union européenne
trouver de nouveaux partenaires et
notamment et partenaires économiques
dans cette tradition du libre-échange
britannique donc des comptes est demeuré
jeune sean healy à une volonté de faire
en sorte que le maximum de piscine avec
la grande bretagne les accords de libre
échange
du côté démocrate du côté des états unis
du côté de l'eau maiden c'est un retour
plutôt vers le protectionnisme américain
hey man secrétaire d'état responsable
des finances américaines va très bien
10 c'est que tout simplement il ne faut
pas s'attendre à cette économie ouverte
tels que les états unis à propager la
propagent cancer mais pour eux mêmes ils
sont plus protectionniste donc là il y a
des différences des divergences
d'intérêts entre la bretagne et les
etats unis les états unis est ce qu ils
cherchent également à un moyen de
contrer les certaines puissances
étrangères en renforçant ses liens
commerciaux avec le royaume uni selon
vous alors il va y avoir un véritable
débat entre l'europe c'est bien l'union
européenne et les etats unis selon un
débat que sur la question fondamentale
c'est la question de la stratégie de la
défense
hélas il y a des différences importantes
entre les membres de l'union européenne
à ce niveau et certainement du côté
américain il y aura un jour billard si
vous voulez on fera en sorte de toujours
chercher le partenaire le plus apte à
préserver les intérêts américains parce
qu'il faut bien comprendre et je crois
que c'est une erreur qu'on fait beaucoup
d'européens et notamment dans le public
admire et européennes c'est que la venue
du global c'est d'être une bonne
nouvelle par rapport à l'héritage trump
mais c'est pas la boîte de pandore qu'on
m'ouvre et tout à coup tout au talent
allait pour le mieux du monde c'est pas
du tout le cas
l'administration démocrate ou si une
administration protectionnistes et
notamment en matière économique et
stratégique alors boris johnson qui a
perdu un allié de taille avec le départ
de donald trump de la maison blanche on
sait que les relations entre joe biden
le nouveau président et le premier
ministre britannique ne sont pas
forcément les meilleurs le président
américain a critiqué le bric cité la
politique qui est menée par
par boris johnson est-ce que voile bien
ça se réchauffe un petit peu aujourd'hui
mais sur le long terme est ce que cette
relation et durable selon vous je
prendrai une phrase que connu pour les
anciennes générations je ne suis pas
madame soleil donc je ne lis pas dans le
marc de café
mais il est sûr et certain que joe biden
va certainement mettre l'accent sur
l'amélioration des relations avec les
pays européens qui sont ouverts à une
très bonne compréhension une très bonne
collaboration très bonne coopération
avec les états unis ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire très simplement que dôme a
aussi défendre et si son rôle
l'intérêt américain en europe et va
choisir en europe et partenaires qui
sont les plus proches des positions
américaines donc là aussi je demande de
garder un tout petit peu de distance par
rapport à cet enthousiasme européen qui
s'est manifestée depuis ou deux jours
clairement il est dans l'intérêt de bail
de ne pas avoir de mauvaises relations
avec londres c'est clair et net
et surtout ne pas avoir de mauvaises
relations de grandes capitales
européennes
sachant que ce n'est pas du tout dans un
esprit de renforcer l'europe mais plutôt
d'avoir une europe très conciliante
vis-à-vis de washington
gilbert casasus professeur déchets de
c'était fribourg merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions ce matin